where did Evolution come from yeah yeah
so this thing
um that from the very origin of life
that took us to today what what what the
heck is that I think evolution is
inevitable in the sense that if you
combine and and basically I think one of
the most uh useful things that was done
in early Computing I guess in the 60s it
started was was evolutionary computation
and just showing how how uh simple it is
that if you have if you have imperfect
heredity and competition together those
two things were three things right so
heredity imperfect heredity and
competition or selection those three
things and that's it now now now you're
you're off through the races right and
so that can be it's not just on Earth
because it can be done in the computer
it can be done in chemical systems it
can be done in um you know at least
Mullen says it's it works in on on you
know Cosmic scales so I think that uh
that kind of thing is incredibly
um pervasive and and and and General
it's a general feature of life it's it's
interesting to think about
you know the standard uh the standard
thought about this is that it's uh it's
blind right meaning that the the the
intelligence of the process is zero it's
stumbling around
and I think that back in the day when
the options with the options were it's
dumb like machines or it's smart like
humans then of course the scientists
went in this direction because nobody
wanted creationism and so they said okay
it's got to be like completely blind I'm
not actually sure right because because
I I think that um I think that
everything is a Continuum and I think
that it doesn't have to be smart with
foresight like us but it doesn't have to
be completely blind either I think there
may be aspects of it and in particular
this kind of multi-scale Competency
might give it a little bit of look ahead
maybe or a little bit of um problem
solving sort of baked in but but that's
going to be completely different and
different in different systems
but I do think I do think it's General I
don't think it's just on Earth I think
it's a very fundamental thing and it
does seem to have a kind of direction
that is taking us
that's somehow perhaps is defined by the
environment itself
it feels like we're headed towards
something
like
we're playing out a script that was just
like a single cell defines the entire
organism yeah it feels like from the
origin of Earth itself
playing out a kind of script yeah you
can't really go any other way I mean so
this is very controversial and I don't
know the answer but people have people
have argued that this is called uh you
know sort of rewinding the tape of life
right and and some people have argued I
think I think I think Conway Morris
maybe has argued that it it is that
there's a deep attractor for example to
human to the human um
uh kind of uh structure and that and
that if you were to rewind it again
you'd basically get more or less the
same thing and then other people have
argued that no it's it's incredibly
sensitive to Frozen accidents and then
once a certain stochastic decisions are
made Downstream everything is going to
be different I don't know I don't know
you know we're very bad at predicting uh
attractors in the space of complex
systems generally speaking right we
don't know so may so maybe Evolution on
Earth has these deep attractors that no
matter what has happened it pretty much
would likely to end up there or maybe
not I don't know what's a really
difficult idea to imagine that
if you ran Earth a million times 500 000
times you would get Hitler
like yeah we don't like to think like
that we think like because
at least maybe in America
you like to think that individual
decisions can change the world and if
individual decisions could change the
world then surely
any perturbation results in a totally
different trajectory but maybe there's a
in this competency hierarchy it's a
self-correcting system
that's just ultimately there's a bunch
of chaos that ultimately is leading
towards something like a super
intelligent artificial intelligence
system
the answers
42.
I mean there might be a kind of
imperative for life that is headed to
and we're too focused on our day-to-day
life of getting coffee and snacks and
having sex and getting uh a promotion at
work not to see the big imperative of
life on earth that is headed towards
something
yeah maybe maybe I don't it's it's it's
difficult I think one of the things
that's important about
um
chimeric uh by engineer Technologies all
of those things are that we have to
start developing a better science of
predicting the cognitive goals of of
composite systems so we're just not very
good at it right we don't know uh if if
if if I create a composite system and
this could be internet of things or
swarm robotics or a cellular a cellular
swarm or whatever
what is the emergent intelligence of
this thing first of all what level is it
going to be at and if it has goal
directed capacity what are the goals
going to be like we are just not very
good at predicting that yet and I think
that uh it's it's a it's a it's a
existential level uh need for us to be
able to because we're building these
things all the time right we're building
we're building both physical structures
like swarm Robotics and we're building
uh social Financial structures and so on
with very little ability to predict what
sort of autonomous goals that system is
going to have of which we are now cogs
and so right so so learning learning to
predict and control those things is
going to be critical so we've so so in
fact so so if you're right and there is
some kind of a tractor to Evolution it
would be nice to know what that is and
then to make a rational decision of
whether we're going to go along or we're
going to pop out of it or try to pop out
of it because there's no guarantee I
mean that's that's the other you know
kind of important thing a lot of people
I get a lot of complaints uh from from
people email me and say yeah you know
what you're doing uh it isn't natural
you know and I'll say look natural that
that'd be nice if if somebody was making
sure that natural was was was matched up
to our values but no one's doing that by
uh you know Evolution optimizes for
biomass that's it nobody's optimizing
it's not optimizing for your happiness
it's I don't think necessarily it's
optimizing for for for intelligence or
fairness or any of that stuff I'm gonna
find that person that emailed you beat
them up take their place
um steal everything they own and say now
we're now this is natural this is
natural yeah exactly because because it
comes from it comes from a from an old
world view where you could assume that
whatever is natural that that's probably
for the best and I think we're long out
of that Garden of Eden kind of view so I
think we can do better we I think we and
we have to right natural just isn't
great for for a lot of a lot of life
forms